[Music]
hello everyone thank you for joining us
live on et's facebook page i'm denny
directo and this vision to my left is
the one and the only nelly furtado hello
hi denny thanks for coming out with us
hey it's been a while since we got some
new music from you so i'm excited to
talk to you and i know your fans are too
so if you guys have some questions leave
them in the comment section i'll be
giving them to my phone right here and
we'll get through as many as we can but
i'm gonna kick things off first of all
how are you i'm amazing yeah i'm super
happy yeah it's a sunny day and uh
yeah it's fun to have um
be able to sit here and like talk to you
about my album i mean we've talked about
this it's been nearly five years since
the last record totally nearly five
years right legit it's been four and a
half i guess officially but still it
feels like you know it's about five
let's just say five and i know fans are
eager for this new music and you know
yeah tell us about that weight like what
were you doing during that time and were
you marinating on this on this new stuff
i kind of was i mean i'll never stop
writing songs it's in my blood it's what
i've been doing since i was a little
girl i love doing it i do it even when i
don't record the songs i sing to myself
in my car i sing to myself in the shower
i just like i'm always singing and
writing songs so this particular album
is super personal like it's really raw
and honest i kind of went through some
challenges kind of personally and just
trying to figure out like
when do we start to take the journey
within and really ask ourselves the
tough questions and make sure
we're going in life going after things
we truly want and i took some time
pursue a few hobbies and just kind of
slow things down and get back to really
making songs from this really pure
simple kind of place um because when you
tour internationally and you've got this
big kind of circus traveling around the
world it can be a bit overwhelming and
and i'm i'm a quiet kind of person
actually and so it's nice to slow down
sometimes especially when you hit it so
big so young i mean i was 18 i was young
i signed my first deal 20 years old my
first tour was 20. that's crazy 21 yeah
um one of grammy when i was 23 maybe
turned out hits after yeah all over the
radio yeah
i was young and yeah that's what happens
you put out albums and then your songs
become a part of people's lives so you
really you know there's some you really
share share that and it's it's a
beautiful thing it's such a privilege
but you got to also take care of
yourself absolutely and uh make sure
you you're kind of like your values are
in the right place get back to life get
back to your life right yeah i'm a
mother i have a 13 year old daughter and
i also
again i love the musical side like i did
things like i went back to university i
studied uh i took a playwriting class
wow cause i just wanted to uh explore
like scene studies and just like a
different thing in the theatrical world
and that improved my songwriting yeah
it did actually yeah yeah cause you're
telling stories yeah you're telling me
you're telling stories and um
the the songs on the album are literally
about what i'm talking about right like
there's a song called tap dancing where
it's about like
you can't tap dance your whole life you
know what i mean you can't constantly
and i think everybody can relate to this
like when we we live in a fast-paced
world and sometimes we feel like we're
on display all the time and we're kind
of putting on a show for our friends and
our family and maybe ourselves it may be
facebook yeah maybe facebook
and that's heightened when you're an
entertainer but you have to know like
when you're not on stage anymore right
because if you're always on stage you'll
you'll never have any time to just kind
of like do the inner reflection piece
right
the simple things in life like i read
that you
started cleaning your own toilets again
i did because when i started writing
songs i was a 17 year old girl and i was
working at the robin hood motel okay
this motel in victoria my mother worked
there and i was you know cleaning the
toilet and and and cleaning the mirrors
and i was meditating and singing and
writing songs so i went back to that i'm
like i want to clean my own house again
i want to fold my own underwear
and just kind of i don't know just
getting back into the nitty-gritty of
life that really makes you feel human
and alive and just i want to feel that
all that poetry and um
i think uh it was helpful for me it's
all in that album huh it's on the album
yeah
five years worth of scrubbing toilets
she's got it out there now i mean we
were talking about this earlier pretty
honest record all of your records have
been so different and you've evolved so
so much so
what can we expect from this next era of
nelly furtado okay this era ooh is um
i don't know it's just raw that's how i
describe it i mean the music video is
like oh the other thing is like i own
this album so i'm like a fully
independent artist and i own my own
music and i've had my own label for a
while i used to sign other artists but
now this is my first english independent
project my spanish album was independent
too but this is like to the next level
of that and that's really cool because i
can just kind of like put a song out and
and have it be heard by people in a few
days rather than waiting um longer than
that um it doesn't go through so many
hands too no really doesn't like my
music video pipe dreams um
i decided on the location the day before
really i was in dallas texas and i went
to an estate sale because i like vintage
i like shopping so i went to this ladies
um it was her house she lived in there
but now it was a sale for all her items
and i liked her house because it had so
much history i mean she looked she lived
there like 50 years or something and um
so then i asked them if i could film
this video and um
they yeah they said i could come back
and shoot the next day so we went and
shot the video that is a gorgeous video
by the way it's like it looks like a
shot on home video it is
it really is it's not an effect it's not
a treatment it's actually shot on a i
think it's an early 90s sort of digital
camera right yeah that was shot by the
director so think you know thinking
ahead of the visuals for this album and
your upcoming singles is that the
direction you're going or you know yeah
it's very organic everything i've done i
did a little mini movie called um it's
kind of like the ride and it kind of
talks about it's really taking the veil
off and i always call it like my
hangover album because it's like what
sure the party's fun but what happens in
the morning after right and that's the
interesting part is the songs are still
like quite like jugular and exciting and
like they move they're not like mellow
songs they're upbeat they're more
confrontational but it's almost like the
mirror confrontation like kind of like
all right you know like
that i don't know
yeah so that's amazing well the name of
the album is the ride yeah the ride so
talk to me about the significance behind
that like what does the ride mean yeah
well um i recorded this album in dallas
texas and um there's a sort of like um
i think it's john hicks i want to
misquote it but he has this great like
essay called the ride and the ride is
this the ride is that and my producer
john connollton is from texas we were in
texas recording a lot and it was just a
great vibe i met so many artists and he
saw me struggling i wrote down a hundred
titles
and i couldn't figure out what to call
my album and i already did the whole
like name and album after a song thing
last time with the spirit indestructible
so one day he looked at me and said hey
have you thought of calling your album
the ride there's this great quote and i
read it
and i said yeah that's a great title and
i think sometimes the people around you
can see what you're going through before
you can and i think he was like whoa
she's been through a lot of stuff
and he was like wow she's got a lot to
say it's like a ride right you know and
i have a song called carnival games when
we literally went to the carnival and
went on the rides the last album because
in texas the big the big um
carnival is the texas state fair state
fair texas
and uh
it's so amazing they have like fried
everything right they even have fried
soda i don't know how that works funnel
cake corn dogs i've been there
yeah yeah yeah exactly well that's
awesome i do want to get to a fan
question uh george says has the ride
been one of the most enjoyable albums to
produce
oh hello
hi hi george you're right there
um hello george
the ride was so enjoyable to make that i
cried on the last day i heard
the last mix of carnival games and i and
i i just got so overwhelmed with emotion
i locked myself in the washroom in the
little studio and john works in a studio
that used to be a funeral home so
it's got a vibe let's just say and i was
in this little weird little bathroom in
his studio and i and i was and i was
crying and that's because it means so
much to me to make music like it really
comes from my heart
there's no filter and
i'm i do write the songs to share with
everybody but i also write them for
myself so um
it was enjoyable to
have the studio become kind of like an
island for me to
um kind of put myself back together and
kind of
almost like a confessional booth where i
could kind of confess all my sins wrap
them up in an album and then move on but
moving on is hard so yeah it was a hard
album to leave behind it was
it was a really fun time i have fond
memories of every album i make like
literally like i always say like when i
recorded loose
i was in miami yeah uh you know the the
the days were long the nights were long
and it was just a fantastic time in the
sun and worked with timbaland i mean
come on exactly and it's it's that's
what making albums should be like
absolutely you should have these like
really poignant memories of that time in
your life and
i almost and i hate to say this because
i know some fans are like well what do
you mean you don't like singing live i
love to sing live but i love to be in
the studio making music i love it i'm so
involved i write my songs i i often
co-produce a lot of my music sometimes i
even program little things on on
keyboards
and i'm
or play guitar on things and i and i
just the process in the craft is so so
rewarding for me absolutely but it's
also a rewarding or maybe a different
experience when you actually get to
unleash them and then also perform them
live right it's like a different chapter
different experience different
experience of the whole i love my
favorite thing it sounds very emo but i
love
i love to like sing a ballad and see the
person in the front row and and cry with
them
you know
that's the moment right the tears are
there and you say wow i wrote this song
kind of for myself but look now i've
given it to somebody else and we're
sharing this emotions we're sharing
these emotions yeah we need more empathy
in the world that's more compassion you
have some die hard fans who are watching
right now i gotta say i'm gonna give
sino a shout out he wants to know what
it was like to work with casino pardon
me for if i messed this up but caitanya
oh my god thank you for asking that i
love you
island of wonder wow i love you great
question
katana veloso is the favorite my
favorite artist of all time so if you
have like this idol like somebody you
love your whole life who's that for you
beyonce see okay
so you love beyonce imagine imagine
meeting beyonce backstage
okay i was so scared to meet katana
veloso so he's my beyonce katano is my
beyonce
so me my beyonce katana veloso
i was so scared i met him in sao paulo
that was step one step two
i asked him to sing on island of wonder
a friend convinced me to ask him i
didn't even i wouldn't want that i was
too nervous
i had to call him on the phone to talk
about the song and i needed somebody to
hold my hand the whole time so that's
like you asking to collaborate with
beyonce
and then on top of that oh then we had
the song but collaborating was amazing i
told him since you probably love katano
he has an album called sazu and so on
that album he start he really goes real
deep into his brazilian vocal percussion
style which is really quite interesting
and quite edgy
i asked him on the phone i mean at the
time he was probably
60 years old and i said you know can you
can you put some vocal percussion like
aras azul at the end so this is meeting
your idol and then asking him to do
something
so then he did it and on top of that
he's sang the song with a portuguese
accent and not a brazilian accent
because he knows that i'm portuguese
that's right and my parents were neighs
when he knew the song was about the
azores islands and sao miguel where i
spent a lot of time as a child which is
uh rumored to be the
remains of atlantis so lots of magic
going on so i think he intuitively knew
this and he gave it that spin island of
one which was really cool because that's
not like because you love beyonce that's
like beyonce like understanding you i
feel like she does
i feel like i feel like she does we get
each other on a very deep deep level uh
kyle wants to know what advice would you
give an upcoming canadian artist
oh that's such a good question okay so
we're very lucky in canada we have a
very supportive arts community i feel
there's still like a lot of grants and a
lot of public
funding and private funding for young
singer-songwriters artists filmmakers so
in the canadian industry i would suggest
just really learning your chops learn an
instrument write songs hang around other
songwriters hang around musicians even
if you only know a ukulele player who
plays on the street outside your house
me meet them it doesn't matter you meet
anybody that's what i did i was like oh
you rap i'm gonna hang out with you you
do this i'm gonna because you gotta use
what you got so whatever you got around
you use it
try writing songs
figure out what you want your voice to
be you know like what you want to say
what do you want to say to the world and
if you don't know that then
you know that's hard so you got to know
what you want to say first so that can
only come from experience and building
community around you and being inspired
by the community you're exposed to and
you're around yes
exactly
that'll happen right of course it
happened to you right yeah i just used
what i got you know use what you got
what you got is good let me just say
that i do want to take it back so you're
20 years old you drop your debut album
i'm like a bird just explodes i want to
know what do you remember most about
that time oh my god the real good gritty
stuff happened when it didn't happen
overnight i had to work for it so i had
to like go on the road and go to like
radio stations and i had to play at
their pizza parties at lunch so i'd be
like hi i'm nelly furtado this song's
called i'm like a bird and then i feel
like i was like on like a talent show
and
i thought well i already made my album
but now i gotta really get people played
on the radio so i'd leave messages on
like radio programmers answering
machines um personalized messages so
that's the part i remember the most
which is kind of interesting so it
wasn't like all the glam moments it was
like the hustle the hustle
yeah the hustle is what i remember the
most what do you miss most about that
time because this is like what early
2000's yeah good times you know we're
getting through like that bubble gum pop
phase yeah yeah yeah yeah people like
you and alicia keys yeah like yeah about
the early 2000s yeah whenever i see
alicia keys we always give each other a
hug because i feel like we started at
the same time we started the same year
and it was like oh my god like whoa
we're still both making music that's
cool um yeah i really love her um but
anyways
that time was fun like it was
people when i meet young artists they
tell me that they're like you're so
lucky that you're around then and music
was better than and the industry was
better and i was like well i think now
is good too but but i think yeah at the
time it was kind of special it was it
was rare it was really rare and people
do people still sing that song to you
when they see you out in public because
i'm brazilian i'm like a bird in here
everywhere everywhere i hear at the
grocery store
i've heard eating elevators um yeah did
you put a smile to your face are you
more like oh here we go again no i like
it for some reason i'm i lucked out my
song that i'm best known for i still
love to sing i love to sing it live um i
think
it's nice because you can kind of like
recycle it a lot of different ways i've
done a dance version
hip-hop version i've done a rock version
jazz
gliss goes on
you can flip it you can scramble it you
still sunny side up i love that see we
gotta see it live again so we can see
what rendition we're covering yeah yeah
yeah
um ashley's
live what advice would you give your
younger self when i'm like a brother
that was a live summer version i hope
you guys were recording that
ashley's asking what advice would you
give your younger self around that time
when i'm like a bird dropped um my
younger self
who
i'd be like
just enjoy it you know what i mean
because i learned that with the first
album first and second i remember like i
took everything so seriously and i don't
think i really like
i didn't really enjoy it it was great
and enjoyable but i don't think i
savored it so when luce ended up doing
well i savored every moment we'd go
celebrate every number one single week
like we'd go go out and just like kind
of make the most of it so i think as an
artist yeah if you're lucky enough to
have that kind of success or that
feeling from something you're doing no
matter what field you're in really i
think you can take a moment to enjoy it
and celebrate the little successes don't
go overboard don't go overboard
but like you know stay disciplined and
focus um and yeah just just stay
positive because your reputation really
follows you right especially in the
entertainment business you really have
to be in any business really your
attitude comes first you just gotta be
kind you know just gonna be kind to
everybody be kind and enjoy the ride
enjoy the ride enjoy the ride right
enjoy the ride highs lows just take it
all in absolutely now your daughter is
13 now is she discovering your music is
she listening yeah i hear i hear my
songs on her playlist sometimes yeah and
it's always surprising and i'm just like
oh she
is that a trip says you that's gonna be
a trip it is and the most trippy thing i
find nowadays because 90s is back in
such a big way and she's at the age that
i was at when i loved 90s fashion and
90s music so whenever she knows like a
90 song i'm like how do you know this
right how do you know this song what's
your favorite no no diggity
street
black street no what's your favorite
thing great part about streaming though
um i loved tlc yeah so i was really into
like their yeah one of us were like even
ooh on the tlc tip i was a big bell but
devoe fan boys to men was my first
concert actually
so yeah all that stuff love it
we have a couple more fan questions
because you're coming in
she's
that is what's great about streaming is
you can go find these albums yeah like
they're they're amazing i'll find it oh
i got my 90s playlist um lucas is asking
which song from the ride did you most
enjoy recording lucas how's it going um
the best recording process
one that stands out for me again it's
like i don't know i like challenge so
much but i guess i feel like the sweet
spots of life come at a challenge but um
the song phoenix the ballad um it was
very difficult to record i wrote it in
england like actually a whole year
before i actually got to do the final
vocal take and by the time we had um
done the final vocal take i had tried
the song in about two or three different
styles we kind of went in this weird
like
bruce springsteen direction at one point
lack of feedback
rises
that was a very good bruce springsteen
by the ad that was very good
and then like john congratulations like
should we ask the boss to be on this
song and i'm like no we can't ask the
boss what if he says no
and so the boss is not on phoenix so we
ended up going with a more ethereal
thing inspired by
john's favorite album by briannino music
for airports so that's what we went with
but it was a challenge so i like
challenges it was fun to try to get it
right so the boss do you have any other
dream collaborations i don't wanna know
this
um okay so shoot ah there's so many
people i admire that i haven't worked
with believe it or not because i work
with everybody
um i'm down for a little yachty
collaboration
was not expecting that we'll take it
we'll take it would you work with jt
again you missed justin oh he's
he's so you know when i worked with him
in the studio uh we wrote a song
together once it never came out um i
think it was called crowd control but it
was fun it's like crowd control
and he's great in the studio he's really
like he knows what he likes he's like um
very classic like he's like some some
writers are like classic he's like a
he's got a classic vibe yeah like kind
of like
i feel like him and madonna's writing
styles are very similar
when i hear their music yeah um they
just have an incredible pop sensibility
right like justin timberlake and madonna
the pop sensibility in their writing is
like
is so cool they know how to make it it's
very innate right yeah it's innate in
them and that's rare all right we're
wrapping up here but i got one last
question for you and it's a serious one
are you ready
you still like a bird
yeah um kind of yeah yeah i would say so
um
i've been told many times like oh birds
always a home
like they know where their
home is
nelly for tattoos
and i'm like well it's a song it's it's
a metaphor sort of um so no no but i i
love eagles i love ravens i love many
kinds of birds i actually love birds
it's it's the weirdest thing that's
awesome um
but yeah i mean i think so yeah like i
mean we're always restless a little bit
right we're always kind of but i think
for me it's been more of a journey like
no i'm not searching as much out there
in the universe for answers i'm
searching inside for answers and i think
right that's that's where we need to
look that's where we're gonna that's
where we need to look we're gonna get an
inside look at
that when your album drops next friday
the ride you guys go pick it up and
thank you so much for coming hanging out
with us you're welcome thank you and so
good to see you danny thank you so much
for tuning in thank you and thanks for
asking questions we love you all right
you guys take it easy we'll see you have
a good weekend
[Music]
you